[Musique]
moi c'est Kamini moi c'est docteur
Sophie je suis trop content de te
rencontrer ouais en plus quand j'étais
petit je pouvais pas jouer la poupée là
on fait un Shui si je peux jouer à la
poupée
allongé entouraine la poupée est une
histoire qui dure depuis 1979 les
poupées Corolle sont devenues de vrais
madeleines de Proust traversant les
générations se passant de la grand-mère
à la mer à la fille il se peut que
parfois les poupées subissent des gros
des moyens des petits accidents et c'est
là que le docteur Sophie intervient mais
elle sera accompagnée d'un autre célèbre
docteur
le docteur Spencer c'est moi alors
bienvenue aux urgences ou les patients
s'enchaînent alternant petit bobo et
grosse opération la dévouer et
courageuse docteur Sophie redonne le
sourire à des familles entières
je serai là pour l'aider
[Musique]
bonjour
vous êtes le docteur Sophie le docteur
Spencer vous savez j'ai intervenu dans
des grands conflits des gijo contre le
playmobil les Playmobil contre les Lego
et c'est moi qui réparait les figurines
le film votre nouvelle interne donc il
faut que tu m'expliques toutes les
techniques de réparation et le circuit
d'accord c'est possible allez c'est
parti donc là on a les poupons malades
qui arrivent qu'est-ce qui s'est passé
d'être précis dans les thermes docteur
Spencer alors ensuite dans l'or
qu'est-ce que tu fais quand tu reçois ça
une fois
donc la partie qui est abîmée si on
a besoin du maquillage si on estime
qu'il est abîmé si la petite fille a
souhaité que le poupon reste comme ça on
ne mettra que ça et on touche à rien
est-ce que tu peux me montrer un peu les
différents outils de la salle de soins
de la clinique oui bien sûr donc vous
avez la partie où on a démonté le bébé
pour remplacer la partie tissu comme je
vous ai dit tout à l'heure tous les gens
qui reçoivent une poupée Corolle en
France qui a été réparée c'est docteur
Sophie d'accord avec toutes ces années
d'expérience est-ce que il y a des
familles qui t'écrivent qui disent merci
j'ai tout un classeur complet de dessin
oui
les figurines que j'ai pu réparer rien
pas une carte pas un merci bonjour je
suis le docteur Spencer voici mon
assistante docteur Sophie vous allez
voir comment on répare une poupée gant
s'il vous plaît
meilleur au prochain atelier
[Musique]
c'est pas gagné
je suis meilleur que vous gérez des
figurines à travers le monde l'outil
forcément meilleur que vous avez encore
beaucoup de choses à apprendre de ma
part moi
[Rires]
notre atelier pour apprendre il paraît
que les poupées sentent la vanille le
parfum vanille est mis dans la matière
c'est à dire qu'on peut pas en remettre
après
vous pouvez me confier la clinique à moi
le docteur
spencerveillance alors je veux moi le
bébé musique d'urgence s'il vous plaît
les ciseaux
c'est une intervention délicate
le Bd peut même sucer son pouce regardez
les yeux bulles et les yeux marrons et
en aucun cas le mien suçon pouce
à Los Angeles au revoir docteur bien sûr
et moi j'y crois la petite fille